their eyes are always looking around
this a nice lunge and steal by
presentist these young man with the
fourth overall pick the nice little spin
move and finish in transition here he's
a work in progress it needs to put on
some weight Anthony trying to set the
screen
[Applause]
yeah a few nights ago he was spinning
and winning with his dunk this time
coming in going over the back of a
couple of guys one hand is slamming and
jamming and rising but jessica lee to
throw it down swinging the ball short
[Applause]
believe in shaping the garden crowd with
his huffing and stuffing today so nice
boys who you chicks with rebound and
Anthony with the three his porzingis
wow what a follow
said draft night in New York everybody
booing the selection Phil Jackson
browser death
dark west
with a nice pass in his sophomore
citizen to his teammate he JP huffing
and stuffing
that's a beautiful pass from Derrick
Williams yep big grant center line to
see what shade then on his head or sing
his steps back puts it on the floor
drives
kristaps porzingis gets the crap
[Applause]
that's why you want to maintain your
dribble that dribble going able to get
to the hoop uncontested and he's doing
it all folks with the left nail that's
going their starting five here is
Portuguese what's up
[Applause]
they run that for Lopes drives fakes
stops hook shot misses
[Applause]
we haven't seen this offseason prevail
we take some
and then Parker challenging them in
transition rejects his shop for cygnus
crabs and on the rebound his third
[Applause]
going into the basket a lot of pure
admission to dump this time laughing
there's that tournament missus
today nobody's blocking him out there he
is rising majestically with this stuff
to read most of all laughs when things
were
[Music]
[Applause]
watch Dudley Dudley he didn't know where
he went
so look at Delhi faked out completely as
KP rise and majestically for just some
energy good defense on Butler porzingis
throws it down on a beautiful pass from
Lopes and the pulse call timeout shirts
are you kidding did you just see that
that's all he gets look at the
athleticism and finish overpow porzingis
finally slips it took a song short three
battle Quinn look out dangerous outlet
pass but porzingis has it goes
watch the ill-advised
[Applause]
explicably
was this rabbit him as JP was already up
for the stuff so I get there get back to
people and hit him and get on a glass
porzingis the reverse slam what a pass
is well fight Jennings right in the rim
and yet throws it out to the opposite
corner and Patterson shot preparation
excellent oh boy what a boom and a slam
toe by porzingis my goodness Stanley
Johnson
[Applause]
and the foul kristaps porzingis gets
them on their feet on a gorgeous feed
from Brandon Jennings defense can be
your best stop it so Quinn allowing the
Knicks again in transition alley-oop to
keep P and he had the chance for the
three-point play remember of a previous
game Mike who were concerned about his
back
look at this tumble that he takes a lot
of stress on his back so I know y'all
effects is he's at the line and
completes this is what I call puffing
and stuff again
[Applause]
right there but Mason Plumlee in the
basket with them posterization this
Carmelo Anthony back in looks slip pass
porzingis drives underneath and throws
it down
or watching as a sideline trying to will
the sun's to their eighth victory
holiday upstairs to porzingis for the
flush one hand styling at the shot clock
gets it and get it off
we feet away from the rent so skilled
rose flicks it out to porzingis great
ball pick he tries
[Applause]
walking away from this say it's a small
world after all a crowd to its feet out
of nowhere porzingis with the finish
here we look where the ball is and where
his hand is then a good play by KP that
time
[Applause]
and this was the other one the
master-blaster transition so KP provide
an impetus now for the Dix
he lays pants so almost stolen back to
poor seconds
[Applause]
Dwight Howard look at this ripple round
pass here by Jenny
yes porzingis goes up he dropped
improper and they're going to check this
to see if it's a flagrant not a flagrant
[Applause]
stuck at 29 a couple of good looks for
Harris to get his rhythm back finish
kristaps porzingis the Knicks have cut
it to eight DP you kind of set out in
the night where there wasn't a lot of
defense early first team that comes up
with the big stops will ramp up by two
it's still a two-point lead kristaps
porzingis with 26 everything's okay no
man it was a great feeling I really
appreciated the gas inside throws it
down again
duping wheeling and thrilling with the
left hand his stuff you see javi
Jefferson
[Applause]
only a gasps seven foot three and
thickener gathered in that alley you any
buzzing with sense gussto an amazing
grace set the tone for the ditch the
steel by Jackson
eet's take a look at a grandeur this
splendor or KP ridiculous shot on one
end hustling back on the other with the
provocative snow and the garden crowd is
in a frenzy after that bar the wave
might be with the one hand his thud look
how far away his hand is when he catches
it but again that length just astounds
us with his agility and I still you know
very adept with the bounce pass this
time a good pass the K feet watch KP
right there ten feet away the dotted
line will not be away Jerry Jerry
throws it up porzingis
13 for Joel
firstly man right here exact to the rack
okay where's ingots back to nil hakuna
fakes the three looks
a gorgeous team watch the magnificence
that a guy he likes it himself
majestically with the Tomahawks top 16
first quarter points for porzingis and
mixed with a nine-point lead no mass the
plaster minced Indiana gets Charlotte's
apart first half had to make a quick
comeback porzingis gets it down well
teaming watch him soar and score just
floated that along the baseline in this
no rebuttals Jack Fred Hoiberg as the
Knicks roar back to within one than this
- porzingis running the floor and
finishing Fortuner to their tire take
the lead for the Knicks with a bit of
five left
it'll be porzingis darn hard to the hole
all even
time out for the panel purrs but Pelican
spawn back there in the game they have
the basketballs got a score each of
those teams you saw then that stretches
had very good sequences
[Applause]
nice spin move in the paint 7:3 we
limited with the nasty stuff look at the
spinning right there the winning master
is at 77 most of his numbers much better
than last year except the abducted wall
in a quick runs to where he goes right
there right into his leg and he came
down kind of awkwardly on it right away
[Applause]
[Music]
keep both laugh bypassing us erupting up
that is stupendous stop by porzingis
rising majestically the ball almost
eludes him
[Applause]
chickens
good stops for singers with [ __ ] blocks
on if you can t
hospitable
his second foot Whiteside after he was
hot to start he is cooled off porzingis
was seven points now inside porzingis
denying Alonzo Gee
[Applause]
good days but the fourth overall bit
[Music]
[Applause]
that was in one rejection the game's
elli78 p73 aloha gives it back
resounding rejection and then the Knicks
come down but they turn it over so
[Applause]
it looks good to me first look tonight
porzingis
big time block
then porzingis that's a block Cygnus
throws it out of bounds with his third
rejection of the game if he taps it in
the Knicks go in transition this time
[Applause]
set the tone for the Knicks the steal by
Jackson
leave Alan Shepard soft-touch long ball
kidnapped ended by young and head to
Stevenson Steven Seagal still pacer ball
but porzingis got a piece of it his
second block of the game
[Applause]
here stepping on his mind
NIC's do not need the fat market in the
rebound excellent defender
Markuson did not quite KP
that live done out on the perimeter you
see at each target double-team
[Applause]
long three pointer or the 150 remaining
here of the half pick-and-roll action
you have to control action other guys
have to move just can't stand still
first I guess four thirty first snaps
porzingis I love look at jail they say
the other way around Anthony's fall for
the foul oh wow Happy's draw for the
father
look at that skill as a seven footer as
a compelling finger in the feint
it's I mean blocking shots against
penetrators porzingis days yahoo it Tim
use the piece from downtown and let's
need to talk it over
[Music]
let's Anthony goes the chains back up
for zingers nice fake fires and hits the
three his second three-pointer as is
truly extraordinary mean I think Phil
Jackson was the first guy I saw describe
it as being a unicorn I mean he truly is
three-point field goal they had missed
their first seven attempts as Chris away
then rejected by Dawn yeah came beated
nor on his case so the timeout has got
ninjas fired up on the defense track
announcer 3b at 7 the bruins gage
nor are teaming up here - the doctor
says
k KP straight on with the three-ball as
his son stuck it over his wife
marques Twitter's a young player has to
stay within himself a lot of emotion
where's Angus from way downtown from 329
for porzingis you know me I'm gonna give
them opponents respect what it's dude
that's just nasty
seven to shoot Terry and then a cool
boat trying to alter in the airport
Cygnus the denial first he altered it
then he blocked it no down great second
effort by both players oh no poor Zinio
[Applause]
it's a one-point game firts
in a row here he comes over that's a cut
once again that's a gets a piece of that
one recovers gets a piece of that one
and then comes down I mean how far is he
buying that three-point line
as step curry right oh my and what did
get it off to a good start
well he has all six points porzingis
tries the three
[Applause]
that was a nice deliver in terms of the
art how they're being careless in the
wall to Jennings zigzags seven to shoot
kick-out porzingis big three win the
rebound back out holiday holiday drives
back out porzingis tries from the right
side that's good a free pointer and the
next after trailing by as many as 12
have cut it to three it catches the
basketball great job attacking forcing
helps and then creating the offensive
Huizinga Dan Johnson all over him backs
it up course inga sketches three-pointer
this is nice action well defended by
Detroit but Katie doesn't need much
space softens up the legs damn big
bucket porzingis three just under 28 per
game Huawei pets to pray for singers
from way downtown and it's 14 degrees
already in double figures be phenomenal
shooting look at this one straight on
with the hoop from down
[Applause]
Coquina again stops looks like he became
famous drugs afraid kristaps porzingis
part of a 701 soon at vows stevenson got
a piece of him right there right on the
arm and stephen was out by the bullying
school with 331
left in the first the Bulls have two
free throws Linux would still have a
chance to tie see the Bulls had a foul
to give
again they deny you that can't be making
them Fame and with that assists Jarrett
Jack with his second triple-double of
his career and the first nip
triple-double since 2012 when Carmelo
Anthony's let go by Brooklyn because of
that aquifer deal porzingis for three
backs down they pressed up porzingis
about